der Durchmarsch des Immobilienmaklers
und Präsidenten außer Diensten hat
offenbar nicht so funktioniert wie
Donald Trump sich das erhofft hatte die
rote Welle wurde schon vor Erreichen des
Kapitols in Washington gebrochen zwar
werden die Republikaner wohl das
Repräsentantenhaus erobern und dem
amtierenden Präsidenten das Leben so
schwer machen wie es nur geht aber
angesichts einer möglichen
demokratischen Mehrheit im Senat kommt
bei Trump und in seinen nicht wirklich
Hochstimmung auf zu feiern gibt es
allerdings auch bei den Demokraten wenig
bis nichts das Versprechen von Joe Biden
bei seiner Amtseinführung das Land zu
einen statt weiter zu spalten ist
krachend
gescheitert USA was nun
nach dem Kongresswahlen kommt Trump
zurück jetzt in der phönix-runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
zugeschaltet live aus Washington ist
Juliane Schäuble USA Korrespondentin für
den Tagesspiegel in den USA und
Buchautorin eines Buches über
konservative Frauen die gerade die USA
erobern und für die politische
Entwicklung diesem Land maßgeblich sein
werden Titel ganz in rosé zusammen mit
einer Kollegin vom Handelsblatt haben
sie das veröffentlicht Katrin Clüver
eschbrook deutsch-amerikanische
Politikwissenschaftlerin und
usa-expertin der Bertelsmann Stiftung
matthewk ist bei uns
europa-korrespondentes
Online-Magazins Politiker
und Professor Andreas Rodder Historiker
an der Universität in Mainz und sie
haben auch noch eine Gastprofessur an
der Johns Hopkins University in
Washington und sie sind Leiter der
Grundwerte Kommission der CDU Frau
Klöwer eschbuck welcher Umstand hat denn
eigentlich den Worst Case für Joe Biden
bei den Zwischenwahlen verhindert war
das dieser Appell die Demokratie stünde
mit auf dem Wahlzettel also für die
Demokraten war das ganz klar ein Punkt
der sie an die Wahlurne getrieben hat
kurz vorher hat nPA und PBS die großen
Fernseh- und Radiosender noch eine
Umfrage rausgebracht 42 Prozent der
Demokraten sind deshalb an die wahloren
gebracht gekommen aber die Welle ist
zerschellt hauptsächlich an der
amerikanischen Jugend das war eine
wahnsinnige Wahlbeteiligung der
Amerikaner unter 30 besonders unter den
Demokraten die eben schon gesehen haben
dass hier die Zukunft des Landes auf dem
Spiel steht und ja und die dann wie wir
jetzt numerisch sehen mitunter das
Zünglein an der Waage waren die USA
stehen ja seit einiger Zeit in Verdacht
in Sachen Demokratie und Rechtsstaat ein
unsicherer Kantonist zu sein können wir
da seit gestern wieder etwas beruhigter
in die Zukunft ziehen also zunächst
einmal ist das tatsächlich würde ich
sagen ein beruhigender Tag für die
Entwicklung der Demokratie in den USA
diese Polarisierung die wir über Jahre
beobachtet haben hat sich nicht weiter
massiv fortgesetzt das entscheidende
Problem dass wir in den letzten Jahren
beobachtet haben ist das demokratische
Verfahren in Frage gestellt worden sind
und auch der Trend hat sich
offensichtlich nicht weiterentwickelt es
hat zwar jetzt Tendenzen gegeben
Verfahren oder Wahlergebnisse und
Auszählungen in Frage zu stellen aber
das was mit dieser Rede von der
gestohlenen Wahl letztendlich die
gesamten Verfahren des demokratischen
Rechtsstaats und der demokratischen
Institutionen infrage gestellt hat das
hat sich offenkundig nicht fortgesetzt
und ich würde sagen das sind gute
Zeichen für die USA Frau Schäuble noch
mal zu diesem narrativ das auch die
Demokratie auf dem Wahlzettel stünde wie
lange wird denn das ein wirksames
Argument bleiben für Joe Biden und die
Demokraten
also ich glaube schon dass sie jetzt ein
Denkzettel auch bekommen haben und wenn
sie gut zuhören werden Sie sich darauf
ein bisschen einstellen selber auch mehr
zu liefern denn nur mit der Warnung vor
dem Gegner wird vielleicht beim nächsten
Mal nicht reichen denn ich glaube die
Welle ist zerschallt an der aufgrund der
Jugend aber sie ist auch sehr schön
aufgrund der schlechten republikanischen
Kandidaten an vielen Orten denn wenn man
zum Beispiel nach Georgia oder nach
Pennsylvania wo wir den das den Ausgang
der Wahl schon kennen schauen dann waren
eben die republikanischen Kandidaten zu
extrem und die Demokraten haben wir zum
Teil sogar darauf gesetzt diese bei den
Vorwahlen zu stärken und haben ein
bisschen gegambelt also ein bisschen
riskant gespielt um und haben jetzt im
Endeffekt offensichtlich sich damit
durchgesetzt aber für die Zukunft gilt
sie müssen selber mit liefern und das
auch besser kommunizieren
das Regieren wird für Joe Biden
wahrscheinlich schwieriger werden die
Kriegserklärung der Republikaner die
liegt ja bereits vor
werden denn dadurch jetzt auch die USA
insgesamt politisch geschwächt auch
außenpolitisch dass man sich jetzt die
Macht teilen muss in Washington
außenpolitisch sehe ich das nicht das
ist ja quasi Naturgesetz in Amerika dass
die regierende Partei bei den
Zwischenwahlen verliert wenn es so
bleibt wie man jetzt annimmt ist es für
den beiden relativ glimpflich
ausgegangen aber das haben wir alle
prophezeit dass das eher das
Abgeordnetenhaus verlieren wird wenn er
die Kontrolle im Senat hat dann hat er
bessere Chancen seine Außenpolitik
weiter zu gestalten wie bisher vor allem
was die Ukraine Hilfe anbelangt aber
eine große Umkehr sehe ich hier nicht
jetzt haben sie gesagt in den Antworten
zum Teil dass eben einige der
republikanischen Kandidatinnen und
Kandidaten derartig überzogen haben dass
sie eben tatsächlich vom Wähler
abgestraft worden sind dennoch sind ja
eine ganze Reihe von wahlleugnern und
republikanischen Hardlinern vor allem
den Bundesstaaten gewählt worden vor
allen Dingen dieses wichtige Amt des
Secretary of State eine Art oberste
Beamter der die Wahlen zum Beispiel
Präsidentschaftswahlen zertifizieren
wird in zwei Jahren
was erklärt denn trotz dieser Tatsache
dass ich Trump nicht ganz durchgesetzt
hat den Erfolg dass Leute die ganz offen
sagen
Wahlergebnisse interessieren mich nicht
es sei denn ich habe gewonnen dass die
trotzdem gewählt worden sind die
republikanische Partei ist nicht
unstrategisch ja nicht Strategie von
Steve Bannon war direkt nach der Wahl
2020 anzufangen die republikanische
Partei datenstellung zu bringen wo die
Wahl erst losgeht nämlich klar natürlich
auch bei den secretaries of state das
ist in unserem Vergleich sind das Beamte
das sind Wahl Eltern unseren
Bundesländern das ist was anderes aber
ja bei in den USA sind es eben
Parteipolitiker und Steve Balance
Strategie war wir fangen mit dem
Pressing Captain an also mit dem der das
einzige Wahllokal das einzelne Wahllokal
verortet das müssen alles Republikaner
sein und am besten Fall magerepublikaner
und was die Republikaner immer wieder
beweisen so extrem wie sie sind sie sind
zum Teil sehr sehr strategische Denker
und das scheint sich was 200 Kandidaten
des standen zur Wahl haben sie gesagt
die wahlleugner waren und die scheinen
mit einer nicht unerheblichen Zahl
durchgekommener Republikaner erklären
make America great again also diejenigen
die
Donald Trump Anhänge die Tram Pisten
Frau Schäuble jetzt gibt es haben ja
schon die ein oder anderen Abgeordneten
die neuen wie auch die
bisherigen Abgeordneten der Republikaner
angekündigt dass sie also die Dienste
Parlament eingezogen sind ins
Repräsentantenhaus zum Beispiel dass sie
jetzt den die beiden Administrationen
überziehen werden möglicherweise mit
meinem neuen impeachment-verfahren also
ein Amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen den
Präsidenten in jedem Fall aber
Untersuchungsausschüsse einrichten
wollen was den Afghanistan Abzug angeht
das ist ja eine Achillesferse der beiden
Administrationen des Präsidenten oder
auch die Geschäfte die der Sohn des
Präsidenten Handarbeiten zum Beispiel
eine Ukraine gemacht hat werden die
Republikaner das möglichst oder so
schnell sogar wahr machen und versuchen
den Präsidenten und seine Partei und
seine Anhänger da in große
Schwierigkeiten zu bringen
ich glaube es ist ein bisschen nicht
ganz so zwangsläufig wie wir es
vielleicht noch gedacht haben vor zwei
Tagen denn die Mehrheit der Republikaner
sie werden das Haus wahrscheinlich
gewinnen dass sie das aus ganz sicher
ist es nicht aber sie wird nicht
besonders groß sein und mit so einer
Mehrheit von ein paar Stimmen kann man
nicht ganz so viel verrückte Sachen
machen ich glaube das ist das ist den
den Druck geben wird von Leuten die
Materie Taylor green da in diese
Richtung zu marschieren aber vielleicht
werden jetzt für den optimistischer
Mensch vielleicht werden jetzt auch
wieder eher die Republikaner gestärkt
die über die parteigrenze
zusammenarbeiten wollen vielleicht gibt
es da ich glaube die die der Tag gestern
ist schon ein bisschen kommentsents es
gibt es gibt ihn noch es gibt Hoffnung
dass er möglicherweise nicht auch mal
wieder öfter zu Wort meldet also ich
glaube die die Messe ist da noch nicht
gewesen aber klar es wird die Versuche
geben möglichst viel mit der
weinregierung möglichst weniger Erfolge
zu bestehen sind sie möglichst viel
anzulegen und klar Handarbeiten und
Afghanistan zieht bei der eigenen Basis
jetzt muss man ja auch fragen ob dieses
Ergebnis den Präsident nicht tatsächlich
dazu bringt möglicherweise über einiges
nachzudenken oder Konsequenzen zu ziehen
also dass das ihnen auch irgendwie dass
er irgendwie darauf reagiert da wäre ja
auch eine Möglichkeit die aber schon ja
in der letzten Woche sich angedeutet hat
nämlich eine ein verstärkter
amerikanischer Kurs zum Beispiel in der
Handelspolitik America first im Prinzip
genau das gleiche was eigentlich bei
Donald Trump schon passiert ist also das
amerikanische Produkte bevorteilt werden
sollen auch durch Subventionen oder
die anderen benachteiligt werden sollen
durch durch Zölle also Importprodukte
wird das sich verstärken diese Aspekt
American first auch durch den
Präsidenten durch die beiden
Administrationen und wird da der Blick
über den Tellerrand in den USA in
Zukunft nicht mehr so wichtig sein
vielleicht in der Rhetorik aber ich
glaube in der Tat hat beiden da schon
gemacht also so sehen dass die Europäer
auch also die ganzen Hilfen die er jetzt
den Amerikanern gewährt hat in den in
den letzten Monaten laufend genau darauf
hin dass amerikanische Produkte
bevorzugt werden amerikanische
Unternehmen die Kommission ist in
Brüssel ist nicht besonders glücklich
darüber es gibt aus allen europäischen
Ländern schon Kritik darüber also ich
glaube dass er muss damit klarkommen
dass das die die Weltwirtschaft gerade
nicht besonders rund läuft die Inflation
in den Vereinigten Staaten liegt bei
neun Prozent deswegen gleicht es ein
Wunder dass er nicht mehr verloren hat
und das zeigt von der Schwäche der
Republikaner und die würde ja der
Kollegin glüver Anspruch insofern
widersprechen dass ich ich halte die
Republikaner für keine guten Strategen
sonst würden sie erkennen dass sie mit
Donald Trump und mit diesen Trump Pisten
keine Bundes mehr gewinnen können er hat
die Wahl die zwischenwahl seine Zeit
2018 verloren im Abgeordnetenhaus er hat
den Senat 2020 verloren und die
Präsidentschaft das runden lecken kommt
jetzt ja aber er kann in diesen
kleineren Bezirken mit seinen scharf
machen hier und da kann er gewinnen aber
bundeswahlen kann er nicht gewinnen und
auch bei den secretarys of state wir
haben ja nicht überall gewonnen wo ich
herkomme in Arizona eigentlich ein sehr
konservativer Start hatte Demokrat
gewonnen wo die Wahl das letzte Mal sehr
knapp war auch in Georgia was bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl 2020 sehr
umstritten war hat
der Kandidat der der ihm damals die
Stirn geboten hat gewonnen als
Gouverneur also es ist es ist nicht es
ist nicht so dass eine Mehrheit der
Republikaner
tramplisten sind ich glaube das ist das
wird in Europa ja auf missverstanden
oder oder überhaupt eher falsch
analysiert
dass das Land ja auf dem Weg ist oder
oder sich im Begriff findet in eine
quasi christliche Diktatur zu verwandeln
wir sehen dass das ja nicht stimmt weil
dieses Mal war auch das Thema Abtreibung
zentral bei vielen Wählern und das war
das war nicht das war nicht ein Moment
bei dem bei dem bei den Außenbeziehungen
bleiben um dann auf die Frage wie geht
das jetzt weiter in den USA auch dieser
Kulturkampf der da ja schon seit Jahren
tobt Professor rötter Geräten Europa
möglicherweise aus dem Fokus gerade wenn
die Republikaner bei bestimmten Fragen
mitreden können aber schon angekündigt
Ukraine Hilfe da müssen wir mal drüber
reden dieses transatlantische Verhältnis
ist das möglicherweise doch eine der
Verlierer dieser Wahl
das würde ich nicht zwingen zu sehen
wir erleben ja eine weltpolitische
Situation in der unter Trump der
Paradigmenwechsel stattgefunden hat hin
zur Konfrontation von Seiten der USA
China als weltpolitischen Gegner Nummer
eins zu identifizieren und das ist ja
ein Paradigmenwechsel den die Regierung
beiden nicht rückgängig gemacht hat der
wenigen überparteilichen konsensfaktoren
in Washington gewesen jetzt ist dann
verstärkt durch den ukrainekrieg der die
Frage des Verhältnisses zu Russland und
der Krieg mit der Ukraine in der Ukraine
dazugekommen natürlich gibt es den
Rechte hat der Kunde der Republikaner
die da möglicherweise die Forderungen
eines amerikanischen
Rückzugs oder eine amerikanischen
Rücknahme von Unterstützung fordern
werden aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck
als wenn das Thema dadurch auf der
Prioritätenliste deutlich
zurückfallen würde ich wollte
stattdessen fragen sich gegen beiden
dazu gehört habe ich mich gefragt ob
nicht in der Kombination dessen was sie
sagen die eigentliche Wahrheit liegt
weil sie sagen natürlich hat er seine
Strategie gegeben die angeknüpft hat an
die Wahlniederlage von zwei
Niederlage von
von 2020
und alles das was dann ihm Gefolge
dessen stattgefunden hat hat sich ja
fortgesetzt in dem was sie vorhin als
Strategie der Republikaner beschrieben
haben
insofern hat es ein strategisches
Vorgehen gegeben und ebenso haben Sie
möglicherweise recht indem sie sagen
genau dieses Strategie hat sich jetzt
als gescheitert erwiesen insofern könnte
es ja passieren dass diese Wahl wird
tatsächlich ein Paradigmenwechsel genau
in dieser Hinsicht dieser von Steve
bannen starten oder darauf
zurückgehenden Strategie bedeutet ich
würde gerne trotzdem diesen Aspekt der
Außenpolitik der uns natürlich auch
interessiert ganz kurz noch abschließen
Frau Schäuble der zukünftige mutmaßliche
mehrheitsführer im Repräsentantenhaus
Kevin mit Kasi hat ja von einem der
Ukraine wird in Zukunft Blankoscheck
mehr ausgestellt die
Militärhilfe der USA hat ja wesentlich
zum Erfolg der ukrainischen Armee gegen
Russland beigetragen heute kann mir die
Meldung dass Cherson diese strategisch
wichtige Stadt kurz vor der Krim geräumt
wird durch die Russen kann es sein dass
möglicherweise die us-außen und
Sicherheitspolitik es schafft das ist
doch noch mal das kriegsgeschick sich zu
Ungunsten der Ukraine wendet weil
einfach die Widerstände zu groß sind so
viel Geld in ein fernliegendes Land zu
pumpen
zum ersten würde ich sagen die Rolle von
Kevin McCarty ist glaube ich sehr
unsicher was die nächsten Tage und
Wochen betrifft denn das Abschneiden ist
ja nicht besonders ermutigend für die
Republikaner oder zufriedenstellend zum
zweiten glaube ich er hat seine Äußerung
an einen innenpolitisches einer
innenpolitische Zuhörerschaft gemacht
um weil er genau von dieser Trump Maga
Basis so unter Druck gesetzt wird ich
glaube der Konsens in Amerika ist immer
noch und das haben Umfrage gesagt bis
zuletzt zwei Drittel glaube ich der
Bevölkerung steht hinter den Hilfen
militärische Hilfen finanzielle Hilfen
keine Soldaten das ist aber bei uns auch
nicht anders ich glaube dass dass das
jetzt nicht dass da nicht der große
Wandel bevorsteht ich glaube die
Amerikaner die republikanische Parteien
muss ich muss ich jetzt schütteln und
überlegen wohin will sie man hört die
das die bisher auch schon nahelegen auch
von New Bridge zum Beispiel da muss man
jetzt drüber nachdenken was da gestern
passiert ist also ich glaube da ist ganz
viel noch unsicher ich glaube nicht dass
das erste was sie machen Außenpolitik
auf den Kopf zu stellen da habe ich ganz
kurz noch einen Punkt ganz kurz ergänzen
ich glaube der Unterschied oder wo die
beiden administration was gelernt hat
aus dem Afghanistan Abzug nämlich im
Gespräch mit den Europäern ist dass sie
das was sie jetzt innenpolitisch
brauchen und da bin ich ganz bei Herrn
kanitschnik in dem
inflationsgesetz und in den
verschiedenen wirtschaftlichen Paketen
sind viele Dinge drin die
protektionistischen Anstrich haben aber
sie gehen ganz klar und ganz ehrlich auf
die Europäer zu der Brief den die
Kommission an Washington geschrieben hat
gestern das hat die das hat die
amerikanische Steuerbehörde eingefordert
Kommentare zu dem was im
inflationsreduktionsgesetz ist das heißt
sie wollen sich mit den Europäern
auseinandersetzen diese
diplomatischen auf Augenhöhe
existierenden Verhandlungen gibt es die
wird es auch am 6 oder Anfang Dezember
wiedergeben zum eu-handels und
us-handels-us TTC aber sie machen es auf
Augenhöhe und sie machen es mit Ansage
und das ist der Unterschied also das
muss dazu sagen dass diese Ankündigungen
ja schon bei unserem bundesfinanz und
Bundeswirtschaftsminister durchaus ein
mulmiges Gefühl ausgelöst haben was in
Zukunft die behandelsbeziehung angeht
was die Chancen deutscher Produkte auf
dem US-Markt angeht kehren wir zurück zu
ihrem offensichtlichen Leib und
magenthema nämlich wie sieht's aus mit
den Republikanern und mit Trump und das
interessiert uns natürlich auch für die
nächsten 24 Monate haben denn die
Republikaner sie haben das zum Teil
schon angedeutet aber vielleicht noch
mal grundsätzlich gefragt haben denn die
Republikaner bei den Wahlen von Trump
profitiert oder haben sie nicht
profitiert der ja offensichtlich auch so
eine Art parallelwahlkampf schon geführt
hat ich würde das Jahr 2024 Amerikanern
geht es ja immer um die ganz knappe
Mitte und was wir an den Zahlen
feststellen können ist dass die Mitte
ihren Wahlzettel gesplittet hat und zwar
auf gouverneursebene ganz oft sich
entschlossen hat dem republikanischen
Kandidaten der keinen Extremist war wenn
man so möchte die Stimme zu geben aber
wenn es dann darum ging wer dann quasi
in den Senat einzieht oder in den
Kongress da haben dann zum Beispiel eben
diese die die Wähler der Mitte sich eben
doch für Demokraten entschieden oder
eben umgekehrt für gemäßigte republikane
und wenn ein Donald Trump ein rational
denkender Politiker wäre dann müsste ihm
das jetzt deutlich zu denken geben aber
da haben wir es mit einem Demagogen und
einem selbstverliebten Ex-Präsidenten zu
tun also ich gehe trotzdem davon aus
dass wir am 15 November etwas hören
werden was uns alle nicht überrascht
nämlich das Donald Trump weiterhin ein
bauchpolitiker ist Frau Schäuble Donald
Trump hier ist er immer der Eindruck er
hätte sich die Partei unterworfen die
Partei bin ich Abwandlung eines
berühmten anderen Spruches ist das so
ist das noch so oder hat auch da die
Wahl möglicherweise eine Veränderung
gebracht oder wird bringen
ich glaube es ist möglich wenn man sich
anschaut wie Fox News reagiert die sagen
die Zukunft heißt von dem haben wir noch
nicht gesprochen
es gibt die Chance dass sie diesen
Klammergriff etwas
lockern können denn ja die letzten also
ich finde es war schon erstaunlich dass
seit dem 6 Januar sich so wenig
Republikaner dauerhaft von Trump
abgesetzt haben das finde ich muss man
ihnen auch immer wieder vorhalten wenn
das ist nicht in Ordnung aber es ist
auch so dass uns viele Republikaner
immer sagen oder auch viele viele sogar
republikanische Wähler eigentlich jetzt
nicht die ganz magere Republikaner aber
eigentlich wollen sie gar nicht dass er
noch mal antritt aber sie haben eben sie
sie haben halt davon profitiert ganz oft
in den Rennen und das hat sich jetzt
möglicherweise geändert danach sieht es
aus dazu zumindest sollte vieles darauf
hin und wenn er eben nicht mehr der ist
der der die Siege ein Preis dann wird es
vielleicht auch leichter loszuwerden und
ich glaube dass das manchen Republikaner
gar nicht so unglücklich machen würde
das heißt wir erleben jetzt ein Abrücken
von Trump
ich gehe davon aus dass so wenn Sie wenn
Sie wenn die Republikaner das nüchtern
betrachten müssten sie zu einem Schluss
kommen dass sie mit ihm keine großen
Wahlen mehr gewinnen können und das ist
das Resultat von heute die hätten einen
Vorsprung von 60 sitzen ungefähr im
Abgeordnetenhaus haben sollen haben
müssen eigentlich also wenn man die
letzten Wahlen der der letzten Dekaden
sich vor Augen führt dann sieht man dass
das die Oppositionspartei immer groß
gewonnen hat in einer in einer
wirtschaftlichen Lage wie dieser und die
haben krachen verloren also werden wir
sehen ob sie ja den den Senat noch
gewinnen das könnte noch kommen muss man
ja vorsichtig sein aber es deutet ja
alles darauf hin dass diejenigen die
Trump stark unterstützt haben die kandid
die die Wahl in Frage ist das
Wahlergebnis 2020 in Frage gestellt
haben die haben verloren und nochmal ich
glaube die meisten Amerikaner sind viel
moderater als man in diesem breiten
denkt ja also einer hat ja die Wahl
ziemlich glänzend gewonnen nämlich der
alte und neue Gründer von Florida ronde
Säntis
legt er sich jetzt einen Dolch für sein
Gewand zu für den Themen den zukünftigen
Einsatz vielleicht braucht er den ja
noch ja das ist ja jetzt die große Frage
ich meine jetzt steht tatsächlich die
Frage im Raum ob es die Republikaner
jetzt schaffen zu tun was sie nach dem
sechsten Januar 2021 nicht geschafft
haben sich nämlich von Trump zu
emanzipieren man hätte das ja nach dem 6
Januar eigentlich erwarten mögen und das
Gegenteil ist passiert hat mit der
Strategie zu tun von der sie gesprochen
haben und man hat sich gewundert wie
stark tatsächlich Trump in dieser Zeit
die Partei im Griff gehabt hat immer
aber mit der aus nicht derjenigen die
sich im Griff halten ließen des Trump
ihnen Stimmen besorgt die sie sonst
nicht haben würden und genau dieses
Kalkül sie sagen es ja das ist jetzt mit
dem heutigen Tag massiv erschüttert und
insofern ist die Frage ob Trump in der
nächsten Woche seine Kandidatur
ankündigt aber das ist nur die eine
Frage die andere Frage ist ob er damit
dann unangefochten bleibt oder ob ronde
Santis das tut wo ich jetzt schon die
ersten Kommentare Last dass er
aufgefordert wird jetzt musst du
springen er ist noch relativ jung man
hätte in sehr umkämpften Situationen in
sehr gut unklaren Situationen erwartet
er lässt sich Zeit und lässt Trump jetzt
erstmal kandidieren aber für die
re:publikaner stellt sich ja nach dem
nach dieser Wahl die elementare
Machtfrage werden wir mit Trump
eigentlich eine Chance haben die nächste
Präsidentschaftswahl zu gewinnen und die
Frage wird Republikaner jetzt wesentlich
weniger optimistisch beurteilen dass sie
das noch vor zwei Tagen genau das
Problem die kennen die Antwort aber die
können nicht agieren weil sie wissen
dass
die Basis Trump nach wie vor unterstützt
ist
nun die Courage hat dann aufzutreten
noch helfen 15 November war ja ist ja
diese große Ankündigung da erzähle ich
euch was was ganz großartiges wenn es
wie wir alle vermuten die Ankündigung
einer Präsidentschaftskandidatur für die
Republikaner ist wie sieht es dann mit
dem Timing für ronde Santis aus muss er
dann sofort springen oder
lässt er sich noch Zeit um
möglicherweise dass ich das Thema
möglicherweise für ihn von selbst
erledigt man weiß ja nicht was Donald
Trump jetzt alles vor hat
auch das ist glaube ich eine spannende
Frage also ich würde erstmal sagen es
gibt uS-Medien berichten zufolge
Überlegungen diese Ankündigung doch noch
nicht zu machen also in den tramkreisen
Trump ist unberechenbar das wissen wir
alles was man glaubt Trump tut als
nächstes tritt wahrscheinlich nicht ein
gesamtes muss eigentlich jetzt glaube
ich noch nicht springen aber aber er hat
er kann ganz starke Argumente vorbringen
er hat er hat meine Date gewonnen er hat
einen wirklich ein ein Teil wo Miami
drin liegt mit vielen Hispanics hat also
gezeigt er kann da gewinnen wo
eigentlich Demokraten im Vorteil gewesen
sind er hat sein Ergebnis massiv
ausgebaut und und jetzt muss er eben
schauen dass Trump er muss Trumps
Angriffe abwehren denn die werden kommen
das angedeutet er hat gesagt wenn
rundesante seine Seite Kandidatur
verkünden würde oder in diese Richtung
marschierte habe er ganz viel momentan
können das muss man ich muss man schauen
ob er ob er stark genug ist das
abzuwehren ich glaube dass er sich
sofort erklären muss weil es sind
wirklich noch zwei Jahre hin und zwei
Jahre Wahlkampf ist auch keine ganz
schöne
Methoden der Schmutzkampagne greift also
er sagt ja er drückt mit Enthüllungen
das werden ganz schmerzhafte er weiß
fast alles über ihn nur die Frau von der
Sand ist weiß mehr über ihren Mann als
er
wird ja auch mit sentimonials
gekämpft also scheinheilig die verbal
Hornung seines Nachnamens kann ja immer
sagen wer solche Parteifreunde hat er
braucht keine Feinde mehr ist das wird
da gilt da das Wort bellende Hunde
beißen nicht oder ist es wirklich etwas
was er vor hat und wird er da sozusagen
alle Register ziehen
Donald Trump muss er davon ausgehen dass
er alle Register versucht zu ziehen die
Frage ist was kann run to Santa ist
dagegenhalten wenn ich jetzt sein
taktischer Berater wäre ein Job den ich
mir nie antun würde würde ich ihm sagen
er soll warten er soll die Füße still
halten er hat was nachzuweisen in
Florida auch in den ewigen
amerikanischen kulturkriegen die ja eine
ganz große Rolle spielen für das Amerika
von heute wenn es um die Rechte von
Minderheiten geht er hat in einen ein
wahnsinnigen publicity-stand hingelegt
in den Thema mehrfach für eine Millionen
Dollar Flüchtlinge aus Florida hat
fliegen lassen nach Neuengland um quasi
Washington immer wieder zu zeigen ich
lass bestimmte Politik nicht auf mir
sitzen er hat auch Donald Trump schon
damals das Leben schwer gemacht als es
um covid und verschiedene Impfkampagnen
und Ansätze der Bundesregierung ging
also rondes Handys ist ein total
ausgebuchter cleverer Politiker und wenn
man allein auf seinem
Bildungshintergrund schaut dann weiß man
erst weit cleverer als Donald Trump und
in dem Sinne eben vielleicht auch weit
gefährlicher denn er hat eben auch ganz
grundsätzlich demokratische Prinzipien
in seinem Bundesstaat nach Hurricane Ian
auch schon ausgesetzt also vor run the
sentes muss man sich in Acht nehmen das
muss Donald Trump aber das muss auch der
Rest Amerikas ja aber das ist ja
möglicherweise etwas was die
republikanische Basis gut findet wenn
einer mit diesem Elan außerdem noch 30
Jahre jünger als Donald Trump da antritt
dass man sagt eigentlich sollte er es
machen damit man wirklich wieder 2024
die Chance hat das ein
Republikaner ins Weiße Haus einzieht das
wäre eine nüchterne Betrachtung aber
diese Basis ist ja alles anders als
nüchtern also man muss sich ja diese
Partei vor allem wo es um die Basis geht
ja eher als als Kult vorstellen und
Trump ist der Anführer der wird hier
nicht aufgeben und die werden im folgen
bis zum bitteren Ende obwohl es ja zig
vernünftige Argumente dafür keine Chance
hat also wenn Trump sagt er will das
machen er macht ihn fertig also die die
re:publikaner werden sich zerfleischen
und das wäre für den beiden der beiden
betet wahrscheinlich jeden Abend dass
der Trump ja noch mal antritt weil dann
weiß er dass er gewinnen kann sonst also
gegen
ist hätte er glaube ich einen ziemlich
schweren Stand
aber aber Trump ist besiegbar und das
haben wir wie gesagt in den letzten
Wahlen immer wieder gesehen Frau
Schäuble wie sie das aus aus Sicht der
USA Korrespondentin der ist das fällt
jetzt eine Vorentscheidung für die
Präsidentschaft wird descent ist auch
trotz seiner Andeutungen der gemacht hat
der Kampf ist nicht noch nicht zu Ende
und seine Anhänger haben ja gestern in
Miami skandiert nicht another for yours
also nochmal vier Jahre sondern also too
years also nur zwei Jahre obwohl er ja
für vier Jahre gewählt worden ist das
ist ja auch sehr aufmerksam registriert
worden
dass sie das in Florida wollen das
glaube ich auch ob der sandte sich damit
automatisch im ganzen Land durchsetzt
kann man glaube ich zu jetzigen
Zeitpunkt auch noch nicht sagen er ist
eigentlich er ist nicht wirklich
charismatisch mag die Medien wirklich
gar nicht also er hält ja auch
Journalisten ganz weit von sich fern
nicht nur deutsche Journalisten das geht
uns öfter so auch amerikanische und die
Frage wenn er dann auf nationaler Ebene
punkten will ob das so gut klappt wie in
Florida wo das Leben ein bisschen anders
ist als in anderen Bundesstaaten dass da
würde ich auch mal noch mal ein
Fragezeichen hinmachen ich glaube zwei
Jahre vor der nächsten Wahl ist gar
nichts sicher und und das ist auch wahr
wenn die replikaner sich zerfleischen
dann kann der lachende Dritte Joe beiden
heißen oder wer auch immer dann für die
Demokraten antritt den Demokraten können
wir gleich noch mal aber zu dieser ist
noch mal er wird ja auch als Trump mit
Hirn bezeichnet
wo ist denn der Unterschied Donald Trump
jetzt nicht nur im Charakter und im
Alter sondern auch inhaltlich
psychologisch oder gibt es da eigentlich
gar keinen
er war eigentlich deutlich moderater als
angefangen hat allerdings war Trump auch
mal Demokrat also ich glaube das ist gar
nicht furchtbar wichtig sondern man
schaut eben was zieht und da hat er
gesehen und von Trump gelernt mit den
kulturkämpfen kann er punkten da kriegt
er die Aufmerksamkeit dass der Stand mit
den Flüchtlingen war aus
republikanischer Sicht genial weil er
natürlich bei vielen Leuten sagt naja
dann müssen die halt meinen Masters bin
ja so ein bisschen sich um die
Flüchtlinge kümmern die haben ja
genügend Geld also da ist er sehr schlau
ich würde aber auch an dieser Stelle
noch sagen es gibt auch ganz andere
spannende Republikaner die wir nicht
vergessen sollten da ist wenn junkin in
Virginia und da ist briancamp in Georgia
die zeigen es gibt auch noch einen Weg
als Republikaner erfolgreich zu sein
vielleicht ist das sogar der der eher
zieht dass man diese Radikalität dann
tatsächlich wieder ein Stück weit
zurücknimmt in der republikanischen
Partei
gesendet hat ja im Wahlkampf auch gesagt
der hat von Vogue Pöbel gesprochen also
linken und liberalen dieser Kulturkampf
der ja auch von Trump angeheizt worden
ist vertieft er jetzt in diesen 24
Monaten bis zur bis zur
Präsidentschaftswahl noch weiter die
Gräben in den USA die Themen die sind
gesetzt also das ganze die ganze Frage
um die
abtreibungsdynamik und die Rechte der
Frauen also das erste Mal noch mal dass
ein oberster Gerichtshof Amerikanern
Rechte aberkannt hat und wir haben
gesehen zu welchen Folgen das jetzt
nicht nur in dieser Wahl geführt hat
aber eben schon zum Beispiel auch schon
bei Vorabstimmungen im Bundesstaat
Kansas zum Beispiel eigentlich ein eher
konservativer Staat wo sich Frauen zur
Wahl registriert haben die sonst nie
vielleicht an die Wahlurne gegangen
werden jetzt hat der Oberste Gerichtshof
gerade große Fragen auch wieder zur
Gleichheit zwischen den
unterschiedlichen pluralistischen
Gruppen in USA auf dem Tisch also die
Themen lassen Amerika nicht los und ein
oberster Gerichtshof der konservativ
besetzt ist entscheidet gerade über die
Zukunft der der funktionierenden
pluralistischen Demokratie das heißt es
wird da irgendwo auf Straßenkampf auch
geschaltet werden und so haben sich die
beiden Parteien daneben entsprechend
auch positioniert und das ist ja immer
das spannende wenn wir nach Amerika
gucken gerade in einem solchen Wahlkampf
einerseits haben wir gesprochen über die
200 wahlleugner und andererseits schauen
wir uns an wer dann Wahlsiege
eingefahren hat in meinem Bundesstaat
die erste lesbische Gouverneurin
weibliche Gouverneurin in der Geschichte
Amerikas auch das ist Amerika das heißt
diese Spannungen wird das Land weiter
aushalten müssen aber die werden durch
bestimmte Themen ganz klar in zwei
langen Jahren noch hier und da an die
Spitze getrieben werden ohne Frage was
diese Spaltung in den USA angeht ist das
eigentlich allein von Trump zu
verantworten das dieses Land in einem
solchen Gegensatz zeigen
politischer Gruppierungen und ihrer
Anhänger steht und man ihr das Gefühl
hat dass wir jeden Tag schlimmer ich
glaube Trump ist eher ein Symptom dafür
die sind diese Auseinandersetzungen gab
es ja schon vor Jahrzehnten also seit
der ersten Entscheidung des Obersten
Kriegs oder so ich würde meinen dass die
Frauen ja immer noch dieses Recht haben
wie sie in Kansas bewiesen haben und
jetzt den in Michigan und und anderswo
weil es wird ja in den einzelnen
Bundesstaaten abgestimmt ob Frauen
direkt auf Abtreibung haben sollen
das sind Dauerbrenner auch also was das
Waffenrecht anbelangt Trump hat es
natürlich auf die Spitze getrieben aber
wenn es um Brocken es geht zum Beispiel
ja also solche Töne hört man ja auch aus
der Union in Deutschland also das ist so
abwegig ist es nicht das sind das sind
Themen die die Leute beschäftigen in
Amerika und in Europa auch im übrigen
und das wird ja weitergehen einen halben
Punkt noch die Demographie ist in
Amerika entscheidend ja wir in kürzester
Zeit ein Minoritäten also minority
majority country sein und da lässt sich
an der demografischen Uhr nicht viel
zurückdrehen das heißt bestimmte
Deutschland ja aber was heißt das aber
was heißt das wenn wir nach Florida
schaut zum Beispiel
genauso interessant weil das ist ja die
spanische
spänex in Arizona ja genau aber eben
nicht deswegen bleibt deswegen bleibt
er mich anzuschauen denn die
Gesellschaft verändert sich weiter und
sie verändert sich schnell aber welche
Auswirkungen das hat und wie dann
bestimmte ja spalterische Argumente
politisch genutzt werden wir sind da ja
gar nicht auseinander sondern eigentlich
sind wir beieinander das ist ja das
Spannende was eine solche Demokratie ein
Schmelztiegel ausmacht und da hinten
dann wieder die Vergleiche leicht zu
Europa weil diese Situation haben wir
natürlich nicht jedenfalls gibt es keine
Automatismen in dieser Entwicklung das
ist ja oft gesagt worden mit zunehmenden
zunehmender Zahl oder gut zu dem Anteil
der Hispanics wird es den Demokraten
nützen das ist ja die eigentlich
überraschende Entwicklung schon bei der
letzten Präsidentschaftswahl gewonnen
gewesen das ja schon Trump relativ viele
Hispanics hat mobilisieren können und
Disentis tut es jetzt auch also insofern
sind da sehr viel tatsächlich
überraschungsfaktoren und
Entwicklungspotenziale die man gar nicht
wirklich absehen kann am Start
aber ich wollte noch gerne eines sagen
was die kulturkämpfer angeht ich meine
interessant ist doch ich würde das etwas
anders werden man hat als der Supreme
Court Rovi Wade nach über 50 Jahren
zurückgenommen hat
abtreibungsprozess der frühen 70ern hat
man ja gesagt jetzt bricht dieser
Kulturkampf ganz massiv aus aber
insgesamt ist das ganze doch längst
nicht so hoch gegangen wie man jetzt im
zweiten Halbjahr im Vorlauf der der
Mitte Wahlen wie man das eigentlich
gedacht hätte eine Isolation sie haben
von der Abstimmung in Kansas gesprochen
also man hat ja gedacht jetzt explodiert
das ganze und wird zu einem riesen Thema
überall in den Staaten mein Eindruck ist
das ist nicht der Fall gewesen und die
nächste Unsicherheit ist tatsächlich die
die sie sagten die Inflation kommt jetzt
hat das Thema verdrängt meinte ich jetzt
so wenn wir von den nächsten zwei Jahren
sprechen hat das ja Potenzial noch viel
gravierender zu werden wenn sich das
alles wirklich auswirkt Frau Schäuble
ganz kurz noch dies wenn man die Bilder
gesehen hat
diesen Urteil des Obersten Gerichtshofs
zum Thema
Abtreibungsgesetze das weiße quasi
liquidiert hat aus dem Jahr 1972 und
immer Bilder gesehen vom Protestierenden
Frauen USA spielt der Feminismus eine
große Rolle die me2-bewegung kommt daher
aber sie haben ja in ihrem Buch jetzt
geschrieben dass die Konservativen
Frauen eigentlich die USA erobern
macht sich da auch eine zwei machen sich
da im Bereich der Frauen zwar völlig
unterschiedliche Kulturen bemerkbar die
gegeneinander arbeiten die eigentlich
für ganz andere Werte auch stehen
ja ich glaube auch da ist die
Polarisierung da und was Annett mairitz
meine Kollegin vom Handelsblatt und ich
geschrieben haben und
rausgefunden haben aus unserer Sicht ist
eben dass dass diese Bewegung viel
stärker ist und viel geeinter ist als
wir das auch gedacht haben und
unglaublich gut vernetzt und ohne diese
diese diese konservative Frauenbewegung
wäre hätte das so nicht beurteilt und da
würde ich mich auch nur auf manches
einstellen denn die sind die sind nicht
leiser geworden und die haben auch nicht
vorleist zu sein da habe ich noch ein
paar Fragezeichen was den gestrigen Tag
betrifft also sind die so zur Wahl
gegangen wie wir das auch erwartet haben
oder nicht also ist der waren die
Republikaner vielleicht schon wieder
zufrieden nach lobbyway das ist noch
eine Frage die offen ist aber sie sind
sehr sehr motiviert und sie sind sehr
motiviert die Gesellschaft in ihrem
Sinne zu verändern weil sie sagen ich
kann auch eine Feministin sein die
konservativ ist das ist doch meine
eigene Entscheidung und da glaube ich
haben wir noch so ein bisschen manchmal
meine blinden Fleck das ist wie bei den
wie bei nix auch viele viele
schwarzen Republikanerin gesprochen die
sagen eigentlich dürfte mich gar nicht
geben wenn man den Demokraten zuhört ist
es ist ein Widerspruch aber wir sind so
und wir stimmen ja nicht nur ab nach
einem Thema sondern der entscheiden uns
je nachdem welche Partei unsere
Interessen generell mehr vertritt das
ist ein Widerspruch dass gerade die
Linken Frauen in der bei den Demokraten
die sogenannte squad-gruppe Alexandria
und andere alle mühelos ihr Mandat
wieder errungen haben oder lag das
einfach daran dass sie in wahlgebieten
antreten wo sie einfach
dominant oder Dominanz erwarten könnt
für ihre Position
ja ich würde schon sagen dass New York
bei allem was wir darüber gesprochen
haben dass New York vielleicht die
gouvernresswahl anders dreht aber denen
aber Alexander occasio Cortez ist ist da
ist da eben auch eine inzwischen ein VIP
und zieht auch bei vielen unglaublich
gut mobilisieren aber das können die
anderen eben auch und jetzt wird zurzeit
reden wenn ich viel über die nächste
Präsidentin aber ich würde mal nicht
ausschließen dass es da auch ganz
interessante kantendatinnen geben wird
gut das war jetzt ein Stichwort auch in
Bezug auf die Demokraten das
Wahlergebnis und gestern hat ja
zwangsläufig mitgebracht dass wir den
Präsidenten und seine Partei etwas
stiefmütterliche behandelt haben in
dieser Sendung aber das wollen wir jetzt
noch ändern ja wie sind die Demokraten
eigentlich aufgestellt jetzt Frage dass
Trump möglicherweise ein der alte neue
Gegenkandidat ist kann beiden das
vielleicht etwas entspannter sehen im
Falle von anderen Kandidaten der
republikanischen Partei vielleicht
weniger wird den beiden zum zweiten Mal
antreten naja die neue times hat im
Sommer eine ziemlich verheerende Umfrage
herausgebracht wonach die Anhänger der
Demokraten sich eigentlich nicht nur
still und heimlich sondern eben in
dieser Umfrage ziemlich laut eigentlich
einen anderen Kandidaten wünschen würden
für den Wahlkampf 2024 und da ging das
Füße Geschachere in der Demokratischen
Partei nämlich auch los also ich kann
mir schon vorstellen deswegen sind ganz
interessante Bewegungen gerade im Gange
der Gouverneur
der hatte sich es nicht nehmen lassen
auch ein paar wahlanzeigen im ganzen
Land zu schalten um einfach mal seine
Meinung zu dem möglichen Wahlausgang in
Texas und Florida kund zu tun das ist
schon ziemliches Novum dass da quasi
jetzt schon auf eigene Faust und mit
eigenem Geld quasi aus einer anderen
Ecke Politik der Demokratie gemacht wird
auch bei den Demokraten nicht nur bei
Trump
der geht leiser los aber es wird
natürlich schon geguckt es geht
natürlich eben hauptsächlich darum wie
bringt man die Parteien weiter in
Stellung und was was kann da gehen und
da wird es natürlich auch um die Frage
des Zeitpunkts gehen wenn ein Joe Biden
quasi als Kandidat abgelöst werden muss
oder sollte dann wird es auch darum
gehen wann würden eine eine
demokratische Partei Ihnen einen
Vorwahlkampf gehen wann ist der Moment
wo es am wenigsten gefährlich ist das
ist nicht nach außen internationalen
Partnern gegenüber wir sind in der Mitte
eines ukrainekrieges immer noch
signalisiert die USA sei schwach können
sich nicht entscheiden hätte keine
führungskapazität nach ihnen nach außen
das werden schwierige Momente für die
Demokratische Partei sein diese Dinge zu
entscheiden aber die Basis schaut sehr
skeptisch auf Joe bei also wenn man
jetzt sagt bei den Republikanern können
es möglicherweise doch einen Hauen und
Stechen geben mal Trump nicht mehr so
ganz unangefochten ist wie sieht das
dann bei den Demokraten aus ist das
könnten die auch in Schwierigkeiten
geraten bei der Frage soll bereiten noch
mal antreten er ist 82 Jahre alt wenn er
wieder gewählt werden soll
ich sehe das ein bisschen anders also
ich glaube wenn er noch einmal antreten
will dann wird er das machen und da wird
nur zum und andere Anwärter keine
Möglichkeiten haben weil das ein Unding
ist und die Demokratische Partei hat ja
andere Sitten vielleicht als die
Republikaner und für einen amtierenden
Präsidenten
es ist eigentlich immer so dass er das
Vorrecht auf eine weitere Kandidatur hat
ich glaube dieses Ergebnis stärkt Ihnen
auch
seine Umfragewerte sind natürlich nicht
die besten die sieht aber immer noch
besser als die von Donald Trump und ich
glaube viele Amerikaner wollen ganz
einfach Stabilität und das verkörpert
der die wollen ein Ende des Chaos und
obwohl er nicht perfekt ist würden viele
sagen lieber den alten Joe als den
verrückten dort und ich gehe davon aus
dass er noch einmal antreten wird aber
das sind ja die beiden ganz
unterschiedlichen Szenarien die sich im
Moment abzeichnen und insofern ist der
15 November wenn Trump ist ankündigen
sollte oder Frau Schäuble hat es ja
gesagt es wird hiermitdorf schon gesagt
man soll jetzt die Nachwahl in Georgia
abwarten aber dann reden wir vom
Dezember und nicht vom November und
insofern ist zwar noch zwei Jahre hin
aber passiert im Moment schon etwas
Entscheidendes denn das beiden
unangefochten wieder kandidieren würde
ist ja eigentlich nur zu erwarten für
den Fall dass Trump wieder antritt und
insofern wenn Trump jetzt seine
Kandidatur ankündigt würden diese Karten
auf dem Tisch liegen und dann würden
sich einerseits für die Afrikaner die
Frage stellen die wir vorhin diskutiert
hatten auf der anderen Seite aber auch
für beiden eine ganz andere ratio
ergeben noch mal zu kandidieren kann man
sich wirklich vorstellen dass Joe Biden
mit deutlich über 80 und der Performance
die ja aufbringen gegen einen Jungen
rondesientes oder wen auch immer bei der
nächsten Präsidentschaftswahl antreten
würde das würde ganz massiv schwierig
für beiden werden insofern habe ich den
Eindruck um es knapp zu sagen wir haben
die Wahl ob wir Trump gegen beiden haben
oder zwei ganz andere Kandidaten haben
wird und das zeichnen sich unter
Umständen zwei radikal unterschiedliche
Szenarien für die politische Ziele der
Sendung schon eine Frau Schäuble könnte
man sich auch vorstellen dass Joe Biden
in voller Coolness und souveränitätern
sagt im nächsten über nächsten Jahr ich
mache das nicht mehr ich gebe einem
Nachfolger Nachfolgerin eine Chance weil
ich möglicherweise auch da eine
Belastung für meine Partei bin
wenn das tut er kann sein Amt direkt
abgeben und dann Kamilla Harris
übergeben das ist aber glaube ich die
eher nicht so ganz wahrscheinliche auch
gar nicht Bezug auf die Wahl jetzt dass
er nicht noch mal antritt
ja ich glaube ich stimme voll darin
überein dass er diese Entscheidung
trifft und wenn er sie trifft dann wird
es erstmal so kommen ich glaube nicht
dass es ein komplettes
Vorwahl gibt es wird keine keine keine
keine geben Kandidaten gegen ihn geben
das kann ich mir bei den Demokraten
nicht vorstellen und so man kann auch
sagen er war strategisch ja gar nicht so
schlecht mal wieder denn er hat sie
haben ihr den sie ganz schön
runtergespielt und das ist auch so
typisch beiden oder so einen kleinen
seinen stabchef oder wer immer das macht
sie haben die Erwartungshaltung runter
gedimmt vor den mitturms und haben jetzt
stehen auf einmal als jemand da der der
eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht da
steht nach dem Wahltag und das ist
ziemlich bemerkenswert wir werden es in
den nächsten 24 Monaten alles noch genau
beobachten und es noch mehrfach hier
treffen ich bedanke mich weil Juliane
Schäuble live aus Washington bei Katrin
Clüver eschbrook bei Matthew kann nicht
und bei Professor Andreas Rotter Liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer morgen in
der Phönix Runde Straßen blockieren
Kunstwerke beschädigen wie weit darf
klimaprotest
jetzt folgt Phoenix der Tag mit
konstanzerplatz geht darin weitere
möglicherweise ganz aktuelle
Informationen und Entwicklungen die
Stimmen in den USA werden ja noch
ausgezählt bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]